good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
i am proud to welcome you to this first
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence in
biomedicine where we will enjoy
presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai
applications in the biomedical and
clinical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science
innovation lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material
for our culminating in-person grant
project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville
virginia next june
applications for our biomedical data
science innovation lab program are being
accepted until january 31st 2022 so
please consider applying and or
encouraging your junior colleagues to do
so we look forward to reviewing these
application materials it is my honor and
privilege today to welcome our very
first speaker in this series dr renee
cummings data activist in residence at
the university of virginia's school of
data science
renee holds a master's degree in real
rehabilitation science and substance
abuse counseling from hunter college and
masters of arts and criminal justice
from john jay college and a master's
certificate in terrorism studies
she designed her own bachelor's degree
at hunter college in political science
philosophy media studies and creative
writing she is also a community scholar
in artificial intelligence and criminal
justice at columbia university
renee is an ai ethicist and she holds
the awesome and very cool title of being
the very first data activist in
residence at the school of data science
here at uva
she's been advocating for ai that we can
trust which is accountable transparent
explainable responsible and principled
as well as more diverse equitable and
inclusive she's been on the front lines
of all these different areas of ethical
ai she specializes in ai leadership
policy development governance risk
management and a number of other ways in
which ai can be used to save lives she's
committed to using ai to empower and
transform
the landscape of biomedicine of politics
of policy and many other um uh areas of
uh
of thought
she is on the board of advisors for the
carnegie council for ethics and
international affairs and is the
founding board member of the springer
journal ai ethics she is also on the
board of women in voice as well as uh on
the board of inspired minds producers of
the world summit ai
um and she lectures routinely and
extensively on ai and data ethics and
contributing significantly to um ethical
emerging technologies
so not only are we looking forward to
what we expect to be a awesome uh a
seminar today from renee we are excited
to have her serving as a
2021 2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab mentor so our students
and participants will be able to uh
interact with her directly um at our
in-person meeting here in
charlottesville next june so to kick off
our 2021-22 biomedical data science
seminar series renee's lecture today is
going to be entitled data activism and
the imagination of biomedical data
science this lecture will touch on the
importance of enhancing diversity equity
inclusion and healthcare through data
activism as well as showcase some of
renee's expertise from being at the
front line of ethical ai and data
science
as typical we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording by youtube and if
you're watching on youtube thank you for
joining us also our specially selected
2021-2022
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit
any questions for dr cummings by the
chat feature in their zoom sessions i
will synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of dr cohen's lecture
and with that welcome renee we are so
excited to hear from you and uh here uh
your lecture today
thank you so much jack and let me just
tell you it's just renee it's not dr
cummings so thank you for that uh
fantastic introduction so greetings
everyone good afternoon it is such an
honor and thank you for this opportunity
to be kicking off this brilliant speaker
series hosted by the medical the
biomedical data science innovation lab
featuring such forward-thinking minds in
data science artificial intelligence and
ethics curated under the leadership of
the indomitable indomitable professor
extraordinaire jack van horn and his
most efficient team it is also such a
privilege to be serving as one of the
mentors for the 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab where the
theme is the ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence in biomedicine
the interdisciplinary component and
creative collaborations of clinical
practice through the biomedical data
science innovation lab through truly
excite me and i look forward to the
experience as a mentor i believe our
mentorship is a reciprocal experience so
as i share with you i learned from you
and know that i appreciate you in this
talk i've decided to explore data
activism and the imagination of
biomedical data science and the
importance of algorithmic justice and
advancing social justice in biomedical
research
over the last three years i've been
speaking a lot internationally about
stretching the imagination of ai through
justice diversity equity and inclusion
what we are called the jedi principle
which is so critical to my work because
of its focus on the practice and the
policies of providing equal access to
opportunities and resources for people
who might otherwise be excluded or
marginalized minoritized groups high
needs underserved under-resourced
communities individuals with
disabilities individuals who've been
historically discriminated against and
naturally i chose data activism because
i am the first data activist in
residence at the school of data science
at the university of virginia and that
also
is quite an honor i'm an ai ethicist a
criminologist and criminal psychologist
and therapeutic jurisprudence specialist
and my background in terrorism studies
and counter-terrorism have contributed
significantly to my experience in ai
risk management ai crisis management ai
crisis communication and working with
business leaders to help them
communicate ethically about the ai risks
and building uh public confidence and
public trust in ai from c-suite to main
street i examine challenges such as
detecting mitigating and managing risks
across the ai life cycle de-biasing from
design to deployment monitoring and
evaluating ai systems and bringing
critical and creative thinking to the
ways in which we think about risks and
do vulnerability audits and algorithmic
impact assessments i'm always thinking
about ai governance and justice and
equity and diversity and inclusion which
are critical to the policies we create
and those robust and rigorous ethical
guard rails that are required for
responsible and principled ai ai we can
trust so i spend a lot of time thinking
about the challenges to ai governance
challenges within the context of
fairness and non-discrimination privacy
accountability transparency
explainability auditability safety and
security and of course black box opacity
and how the lack of an inclusive
approach built on justice equity and
diversity and inclusion could undermine
public trust and public confidence in ai
and these ethical risks if undetected
across the ai life cycle from design to
development often spiraled into crises
that create significant challenges to an
organization and that's when i'm usually
called into an organization to deal with
what i call inspired or ai inspired
reputational damage and revenue loss and
regulatory backlash sometimes a criminal
investigation or a media attack or media
expose because of irresponsible ai or
unethical approaches to ai approaches
that diminish public trust and public
confidence however over the last 12
months in my role as the data activist
in residence at the university of
virginia school of data science i've
been focusing on ways in which we can
use data and algorithms to make policing
more accountable and and more
transparent my work at uva has seen the
creation of a public interest tech tool
that measures the algorithmic force
being deployed by law enforcement and
this tool
is critical
because it gives us an opportunity to
bring greater oversight to ai and it
also gives us an opportunity to ensure
that the kinds of work that we are doing
in ai is really being done for the
benefit of all
it is really critical for us to start to
think about ways in which we are
mitigating risk it's really critical for
us to start to think about ways in which
data discrimination and data bias are
really informing the things that we do
it is uh because
of the kinds of reputational damages
that we are seeing in ai that we have
really got to uh reimagine much of what
we are doing and the ways in which we
are are thinking about our technology so
let me jump into this so i advocate for
justice oriented a i design and uh
ethical algorithmic solutions expanding
the imagination of ai and protecting
public rights and looking at public
interest and just about protecting the
public against the the dangers of ai and
that lack of diversity ai that is not
inclusive and of course ai does not look
like all of us so criminology is the
work that brought me to ai i became
extremely curious and concerned about
the risks and these uh risk assessment
tools and uh uh just different forms of
algorithmic decision making tools that
were being deployed across the criminal
justice system the the assault what i
call of algorithmic decision-making
systems on policing sentencing juvenile
justice child protection corrections of
parole and public safety algorithmic
injustice and what some call
computerized racism in in real time the
problematic use of data and the lack of
representation
and the lack of respect for
representation in in the data some of
the many challenges with which we are
faced uh when we think about the ways in
which data is being uh sort of unleashed
on society so data discrimination data
profiling data marginalization data
victimization the monetizing and
weaponizing of our our data but what is
happening at the intersection of ai and
criminal justice is also happening at
the intersection of of ai and and many
other uh uh industries and sectors
education hiring lending mortgages
credit including at the intersection of
ai and and healthcare so race ethnicity
data healthcare ai are creating some
unique challenges medical algorithms are
failing communities of color we have
seen those headlines biased ai can be
bad for your health and also deadly
although a.i hold great promise in
health care and in improving our lives
many healthcare ai systems are biased
and although ai has the extraordinary
potential to drastically improve
healthcare outcomes ai also has the
potential to amplify and exacerbate
racial and social inequality so we
experienced several uh pandemics during
covet 19 including the pandemic of
racism and and healthcare and we
continue to experience how ai encodes
racial discrimination within medicine
and consistently leads to negative
outcomes for black and brown indigenous
people of color and there has there has
been several calls in in health care for
the need to promote algorithmic fairness
for fair and equal health care we need
fair and bias free ai but can we achieve
bias free ai when we have already
experienced the limitations of a
technical de-biasing effort so imagine
the impact of bias ai or ai that
discriminates against uh black
indigenous people of color on health
care outcomes you know think
misdiagnosed under diagnose undiagnosed
missed diagnosis loss of trust continued
mistrust in in medicine in high needs
and underserved and under-resourced uh
marginalized communities or poorer
health care outcomes for for some groups
so healthcare resource allocation
challenges or just uh the dangers of
inaccurate data sharing so how do we use
biomedicine to future-proof healthcare
how do we foster a healthy ai ecosystem
through biomedicine what systems should
we install through biomedicine to
mitigate these harms and long-term
negative consequences of data on society
or ai on society how do we promote
ethical innovation in biomedical data
science how do we engender inclusive
innovation in biomedical data science or
how do we use ai to save lives and
extend lives and protect lives and how
can you in your work remedy some of the
many disparities we are experiencing in
a.i infused health care algorithmic
injustices continue to undermine the
maturity and integrity of many ai
systems uh algorithmic injustices are
creating a trajectory of
intergenerational trauma harm
inequalities and long-term negative
impacts on societies and on the the
question of algorithms we we hear so
much about algorithms across industries
what's the power
of an algorithm how does this unseen
categorical judgment inform the lives of
others how does an algorithm
set the agenda how does an algorithm
assign priority how does an algorithm
shape the the context of our decision
making or influence behavior or how does
the technology we create shape the
cultural economic political social and
environmental and historic conditions
under which we exist and how does
technology new and emerging technology
such as ai create and shape the
conditions in which others have got to
exist and their quality of life or how
does an algorithm connect us or
disconnect us are we limiting the
possibilities of others through the
technologies we create are we prepared
to question the question so ai is super
powerful and i'm very passionate about
the transformative power of ai ai's
ability to create extraordinary
possibilities in every industry and just
about every aspect of our lives i'm very
excited about
precision healthcare and ai's potential
to enhance
enhance everything we do if we get ai
right but the social construction of
algorithms are presenting some very
unique challenges on how algorithms
impact lives and livelihoods and life
chances and opportunities and legacy so
computational models you know algorithms
are being used to disenfranchise and
we've got to think about that and
disempower and to disinvest in our high
needs and underserved and already
under-resourced communities uh
algorithmic exclusion is real there is a
fear of algorithmic determinism the
long-term political consequences of data
and society if not done ethically could
be devastating data is about power
data is about privilege and data is
about politics and data is wrapped up in
the popular predispositions and age-old
stereotypes an agenda data affects every
aspect of our decision-making
data is capital in a data-driven society
data how it's collected how it's
analyzed how it's used many believe our
data is our destiny our data is our dna
we have been warned i think
significantly
by so many scholars in technology and ai
and and ethics about the debilitating
effects and impacts of data on society
and on marginalized and minoritized uh
communities the oppressive nature of
data is no secret and daily we are
becoming more aware of how data and ai
continue to reinforce racial and gender
bias i mean just look around at our
communities and you will see how data is
even used today to uphold uh segregation
and deny black indigenous people of
color access opportunities resources to
to build wealth and often to good health
we have been adequately schooled in the
unjust data practices built on systemic
racism and while we appreciate and
celebrate the great benefits of data
data for good we also appreciate how
data is used to control how data
reinforces structural racism how data
reinforces marginalization and how it
denies access and opportunities and if
we take our minds back and walk back
into that historic uh stream of
consciousness from the very beginning of
data collection in the united states the
first uh census of 1799 enslaved people
were not counted and recorded as full
individuals but rather as three-fifths
of one white man or white woman and not
until the ratification of the fourteenth
amendment in eighteen 1868
where african americans fully counted
what does this history of race and data
say about our present and the future of
data so when we think about the use of
data historically to create policies of
exclusion and segregation and oppression
we think about the data power brokers
and the the data of the elites and the
the private companies that own the
majority of our data
making our own data literally at times
inaccessible and we think about data to
define who is undesirable and data to
define who is worthy of credit or who is
worthy of access and opportunity
wealth and success and and good health
but we also think about how can we use
data science to correct these inequities
and how could we use data science in
particular biomedical data science to
address the wrongs what's the change
that's required and what data do we need
to do the work that needs to be done and
to bring a justice oriented and
trauma-informed approach to ai that is
diverse equitable and inclusive so data
in the best interests of the public data
for civic action data to create
technology for the advancement of all i
mean that is how we supposed to think
moving forward we cannot explain away uh
systemic racism or bias and
discrimination from our data sets but at
the same time we cannot shy away from
the conversations that we need to have
and we cannot shy away from the creative
and uh conflict and intellectual
confrontation that is required to
address race and data in ai we have got
to be intentional so there is an
inherent hypocrisy that we must confront
with honesty in data and ai to develop
the integrity and data-driven systems
and decision-making systems are using
algorithms and we have got to speak
openly and and honestly about bias and
discrimination and systemic racism and
and how something like race when it
comes to data shapes our our world view
at every intersection
data
we realize that the data is not
colorblind and and coded political
correctness will not deliver
the kind of action that's required to
bring the kind of change that's required
to ai ai must have integrity for it to
display maturity and to end the crisis
of confidence in ai created by bias and
discrimination and systemic racism in
the data and we we have no choice to to
do what is right in real time so we must
think of data within the context of of
civil rights and consider concepts such
as social justice and racial justice and
design justice and algorithmic justice
in biomedical data science because these
are mandatory to ensuring human rights
and civil liberties are protected and
remain protected and that is why data
activism is so critical at this moment
and data activism offers a radical and
real-time rethinking of ethical ai it
moves us from a very passive and
reactive position of ethics to a a
practical and proactive and a more
radical stance uh data activism to me is
so much more than its definition and
it's defined simply as which is not so
simple using digital technology and data
politically and proactively to foster
change and what data activism does is it
forces us to stretch the ethical and
creative imagination of ai and bring a
new
and more dynamic approach to the ways in
which we
operationalize ethics in in real time as
we build new and emerging technologies
such as ai so data activism raises our
our consciousness on issues such as
oppression and colonization and
patronization and exclusion and absence
and invisibility and silence in our data
and data activism forces us to reimagine
our data futures together with all of us
in it expanding the range of experts and
stakeholders involved in in how we think
about data and how we think about ai and
and how we engage in interdisciplinary
teams to find solutions to reduce those
hidden effects of algorithms the racial
economic and uh educational disparities
that are are really hidden in in in our
data set so
the future
of data as well as the future of
biomedical data science is really
eternal ethical vigilance in his 1993
book moral imagination mark johnson
described moral imagination as an
ability
to imaginately
imaginatively discern various
possibilities for acting in a given
situation and to envision the potential
help and harm that are likely to result
from any given action so biomedical data
science must live in that ethical moment
of which
johnson speaks and confront the changing
nature of a.i and the evolving ethical
questions that we are faced with every
day biomedical data scientists are some
of our most crucial
decision makers and architects of our
digital future and the future of society
as we forge forward so how do you plan
to use data science and biomedical data
science to address and redress the
negative impacts of technology that have
been felt
disproportionately on communities of
color ethnic religious minorities and
other marginalized groups of
how do we use data science
and biomedical data science to recognize
and to reconcile a long and traumatic
history of technologies being designed
and deployed to track trace terrorize
traumatize sometimes the most vulnerable
and how does that biomedical data
science stay culturally aware culturally
responsive and culturally sensitive and
culturally relevant how do we include in
biomedical data science those who've
been historically left out of the design
and process of technologies in
particular new and emerging technologies
such as ai and how do we offer
communities ownership
ownership in the technological tools to
be designed uh by biomedical data
science an algorithm
we've got to think about it as these
algorithms redefine biomedical data
science how do we ensure the tools that
we are creating these algorithmic
decision-making systems celebrate agency
and autonomy and democracy and
empowerment and
self-actualization so while there are
myriad possibilities
for discrimination and inequitable
treatment by ai in health care there are
even more exciting possibilities of ai
are doing amazing things in health care
precision health care just think of the
extraordinary possibilities but we must
confront
those identities that are intertwined in
our networks the network nature of
algorithmic uh discrimination and
computational code and design
assumptions and cultural stereotypes
which often make a deadly combination
when we think of best practice health
outcomes and also remember
what makes you uncomfortable is often
good for the soul so biomedical data
science has a great opportunity to
rethink models of discrimination and
mechanisms for accountability and
transparency so in your work
i ask you
how do you leverage the power and
privilege you hold to question existing
norms and assumptions about data and ai
how do you defer to the expertise of
communities that best understand how
technologies have and continue to
inflict harm on them
i was uh reading not too long ago and uh
uh
some work from a professor of
anthropology at the university of
virginia and i saw that he is the
director i don't know this is the
current position of the uh bioethics
program at uva jared saigon and he
speaks about data science and he says
it's about world building and what kind
of world will you use data science to
build and he adds we are always in the
process of
or engaged in the process of world
building and we have an ethical
responsibility to think about how and we
create and what we create through data
science and through our actions this
data scientists and how these actions
impact the world and he adds that the
inability to fully predict
does not free us from that
responsibility
we must critically consider what kind of
world we are trying to create with data
science because it involves envisioning
a better world and i will ask you
what is the world we are trying to
create
through biomedical data science how will
the artifacts you create help change
someone's world
how do we imagine a better world through
biomedical data science and how will the
systems you create interact with the
world and impact the world how will the
systems you create shape the legacies
that we are able to create
how do the systems that you create
shape the kind of life
we are going to to live and we're going
to have and how will we
as society
measure your legacy the legacy you have
created in biomedical or through
biomedical data science what will others
achieve through your work
and i will finally and i will ask you my
last question would be
how will you
be remembered and how will biomedical
data science be remembered i thank you
very much for the opportunity to engage
you
renee that was just such a fantastic uh
lecture um you covered so many topics
and it's all so important and uh
sorry you need to take a little moment
there to to uh get some water but i'm so
glad that uh you're able to to rally and
uh continue to explain what are so many
different important topics i want to ask
you a few questions some from
myself as i was thinking about what you
were saying and some that have been
contributed by some of our participants
the whole issue of trust seems to be
fundamental to the understanding of how
um these algorithms and and from ai can
be applied in biomedicine whether
they're for
diagnosis or treatment options or what
have you and we're very as you mentioned
we're very aware of the biases that have
crept in and those are very newsworthy
that trust aspect seems to be so
critical to this and i know that um for
a lot of people in the
communities of color that participation
in research or
basically sharing their personal data is
something they're not they don't
necessarily have much trust in the
system about how that data is going to
be used this produces kind of some data
inequities where just the data that we
collect just doesn't have the
representation that would help us to
kind of incorporate those
elements and reduce biases so how do we
how can we solve that how can we
kind of project ourselves as being
trustworthy partners instead of you know
this kind of one directional give us
your data um so we can try and sell you
stuff or you know i'm not articulating
it well but basically how can we
encourage people to be better
participants as well as
ethicists in this process
thank you thank you for the question and
i think it
really
speaks to
to to to to who
who
biomedicine data science is as a as a
discipline and the kind of work that's
required because it's about stakeholder
engagement and it's about uh community
engagement but i also think it's about
changing the approach and not going into
the communities uh with the the concept
that you're just there to get the
information and and take that into
information for for your benefit it's
really finding ways and this is the
challenge that we're seeing across the
board even now through ai ethics and
public interest technology and how do we
get communities involved in the design
and development of technology so it
really is going to uh
demand much more effort and it's going
to demand new and more creative ways of
thinking about stakeholder engagement
and and how do we bring our people to
the uh you know proverbial table that we
speak about to get that level of
participation me i've been reading a lot
about value sensitive design and then
you know and more thinking about design
justice and thinking about ways in in
which we could really bolster or give
stakeholder engagement a charge because
in uh one of my old existences i you
know i i i
worked as a
crisis uh communicator and working with
organizations at the the c-suite level
to deal with uh crises in in their
various public so i would say that
community engagement has got to be
reimagined
i would say that we've got to look at
other approaches i've say that we've got
to uh respect communities as producers
of knowledge not just producers of data
and i think if we take that approach it
is going to benefit us in the long run
because we've got to defer to
communities as experts and i think we we
we have not really done that we often
say that that is the approach that we
want to take but we do not uh deploy
that kind of approach and it really is
about empowering and sometime in the
empowering there needs to be
demystifying and educating because
sometimes
it is the time uh we have time
constraints and in those time
constraints we need to get the
information that we we want and we want
to get it now but i think uh we've got
to look at that process again because uh
we all know that you know trust is
something uh once it's gone you can't
buy it back you you know it takes really
long to build sometimes it's impossible
to build it but we know that we have big
things to do and in healthcare and
disciplines like you know biomedical
data science that requires the expertise
of these communities and to get that it
requires trust so if we start to look at
our
communities as knowledge producers and
just not as data points i think that may
be a great place to start that's a great
great way to to answer that thank you so
much
several of our participants were asking
about that if you could maybe elaborate
a little bit more on the jedi principle
and how are organizations or programs or
technologies uh actually are they
achieving any of those principles
certainly so the jedi is just the
acronym for justice equity diversity and
inclusion and how critical that is to ai
maturity because the challenges we have
seen in ai are challenges created
because of a lack of appreciation for
such issues such as justice and criminal
justice we deployed all these
algorithmic decision decision making up
uh systems uh within you know the
context of using these risk assessment
tools to bring more efficiency and
effectiveness and expediency to the ways
in which justice is administered and
what we realize is that these tools were
disproportionately uh you know deploying
uh sentences longer sentences to to
black and brown people um uh i think uh
ai is realizing that uh
the days for ethics washing or window
dressing or ethical fear have come to an
end and there are some things that have
just got to be done in real time to
bring the requisite levels of maturity
and integrity that this technology needs
to really build more public confidence
and to build more public trust so i
think organizations and agencies and
then we can see are just even coming out
of the white house recently this whole
call for uh coming uh deploying a bill
of rights to deal with the ways in which
we engage with with algorithms you know
saying that the original social contract
has probably expired and we didn't think
about algorithms how many hundreds of
years ago and how ai and technology is
just changing our relationship because
one of the things uh you've recognized
about an algorithmic decision-making
system is how it can remove agency and
remove the ability to put the individual
back into the decision-making process
and and these things are so critical so
when it comes to to let's just say
criminal justice
you have an algorithmic decision-making
system that is able to undermine uh
procedural justice or due process so you
have someone who's been incarcerated
who's ready for parole and who's
consistently denied parole until that
individual had to take the company the
vendor to court to uh really get into
the black box to see what was
what were the data points that were
saying that they were not worthy of
parole after this individual did uh 15
years of solid time and was an exemplary
uh among uh you know the the
incarcerated and and was ready to be uh
you know reintegrated in society and
ready to return so when we think about
justice when we think about equity and
we think about diversity and inclusion
it really brings uh
to me
uh uh
you know
uh an approach that is so critical
because without those things
what you get is a very immature and
irresponsible
technology that like ai that if it
delivers only delivers in the short term
and then you start to get all of these
crises that need to be dealt with so
they are so critical because uh you know
data activism is is like you know
fighting for civil rights and your
digital rights are critical and i think
more and more people are starting to
realize that you know uh
rights
need to be protected and while a lot of
people are still not you know
ahead of the class when it comes to
understanding the long-term impacts of
the technology i think those of us who
are in those positions or who have the
power and the privilege and the
opportunity need to do the work that
that is required so uh you know i cannot
uh overemphasize the importance of that
jedi principle in your work in
biomedical data science because social
justice and
algorithmic justice and design justice
are so critical to data science
well i i've
mentioned at the beginning about your
title of data activist in residence here
at the at the school of data science
here at uva which is a wonderful title
and clearly from your presentation today
you are indeed a data activist and you
know it did it activism i could just see
how it touches on things like politics
and on education and on you know social
well-being um but it's just so important
in in in science and certainly
healthcare as well
what can we do to bring more
data activists like yourself with you
know people of color people from
indigenous populations basically into
you know to the to the table um as
scientists um you know it would be
wonderful to have more you know
practicing scientists or or
physicians or clinicians part of this
conversation what can we do better to
attract their interests
well i think it also
and what we're realizing more and more
in science is that scholars are starting
to realize that
uh
maybe this uh sort of uh dispassionate
view in which we had in the past uh can
no longer be uh relevant that something
like ai we're realizing cannot mature
without emotional intelligence and
science cannot mature and develop and
continue to develop without that level
of
emotional uh you know intelligence as
well i think what we can do is realize
that in our work uh wherever we stand in
the lab or wherever we stand in you know
the across the healthcare ecosystem that
that we are leaders and that we are
advocates in our own work and we have
got to uh build our own consciousness
and we build our consciousness thinking
about ways in which we are to remain uh
ethically vigilant and thinking about
justice and equity and diversity as a
sort of due diligence framework in how
we uh deliver and thinking about duty of
care and if we think about duty of care
then we understand that we've got to
include that jedi principle in that uh
you know sort of duty of care approach
and and in doing that we've got to
really again i think what ai is doing is
just challenging our creativity on so
many levels because
now we we've got to think about how do
we demystify this technology how do we
uh engage more uh young people of color
into the conversation how do we go into
those communities because much of the
technologies that are being designed are
being designed to use in all our
communities and if you're not going to
get that buy-in then you're going to be
developing and designing and deploying
things and you're going to be wasting a
lot of resources so i think what we've
got to do is really uh popularize or uh
you know the conversation and we do that
by uh ensuring that at every level of
the education system we are having
conversations about ai and data i always
say that ai is is our new language it's
our language of choice right now we've
got to be literate and for us to be
literate we've got to ensure from the
earliest stages our children are being
exposed to this technology understanding
the implications understanding the
excitement of the technology and the
great things that we can do with it but
understanding those great things have
got to come with an ethical push and if
we are to combine that sort of ethical
early ethical vigilance what we are also
doing is creating a certain high levels
of ethical resilience as we move into
the design and the deployment so it's
about really exciting communities it's
about uh just going into those
communities so having the conversations
and if we can go into the communities
bring those communities into our spaces
and into our labs so they can have that
experience as well
i love that um you know the the
fundamental thread i'm detecting and you
can
shoot me down if i'm incorrect is that
it's really education and communication
which is so vital and there are a lot of
physicians who are
really looking towards ai biomedical
tools as basically to help them make
clinical decisions um and it may be
involving people of color or women um
who you know may not be quite
represented in the
to the algorithm and
how can we make sure that um physicians
who are trying to make these very life
and death decisions probably in a matter
of seconds uh understand the strengths
but also the limitations of biomedical
ai tools
well definitely and because the decision
making is so high stakes and because uh
you know ai infused uh medical uh tools
are are so critical as you said it's
about life and it's it's about death and
this is why we need that ethical
understanding this is why
we need you to to build those those
levels of ethical resilience and this is
why in just about every sector we need
to have that ethical understanding and
it's so critical for us to understand
about the power and the privilege and
the politics and data and for us to
understand we cannot take the data at
face value and for us to understand when
a third party vendor creates something
and and delivers it to us we have
certain questions that we still need to
ask so it really is about um there's an
extraordinary amount of comfort uh that
you you sense when people uh believe
that you know uh you know the data sets
are neutral or uh you know that the
things that we're using here are you
know are are scientific and they're
clinical and they and they are just uh
really uh very neutral and those are
fallacies and i think we've all heard uh
you know that there is no raw data there
is no raw data set so it really speaks
for it speaks to a kind of conscious
raising that has had that must happen as
well in medicine and in biomedical data
science and it's really about pushing
that ethical approach to the ways in
which we design and develop and deploy
new and emerging technologies such as ai
and it's about being eternally vigilant
because so much is changing at such
speed and in such scale with this
technology and we know that the law
always lags behind technology but we
also know that we don't need the law to
do the right thing and we also know
that there are so many things that we
need to do in real time and this is why
we want to always ensure we are thinking
about justice and equity and diversity
and inclusion and we are thinking about
how do we exist
always in that ethical moment and we are
thinking about the facts that this
technology could not be perfect because
it's being designed by us and we are not
perfect and always thinking about how do
we improve
you know whatever that technology is
whatever the outcomes are supposed to be
so it really is about pushing forward
and pushing hard and an ethical ai and
responsibly uh and you know trustworthy
ai and understanding for us to do that
we've all got to be involved in the
process it's just not some designing for
all but it has got to be all
uh really consulting and
engaging in in that design and
deployment process
we're going
several institutions are around the
country of developing undergraduate
curricula in data science and with
biomedicine being a major component of
that do you envision that our
next generation of data scientists who
are you know in school now is there an
opportunity there to kind of like
instill some of the jedi principles into
them as you know as part of their
education so it just becomes a natural
thing instead of somebody having to you
know
be brought up to date they just know it
is there an opportunity there i think
it's a huge opportunity and i think
we've got to jump at it i think we're
actually going a little too slow and i
think not only including the jedi
principle but bringing concepts such as
data activism and ai advocacy into the
mix because we've got to understand that
you know this is a new and emerging
technology it's not you know uh it's
it's something that's developing every
day and then all of those views and
experiences and and uh need to be a part
of the ways in which we think about the
technology and the ways in which we
design so i think we really need to move
to move swiftly and i think there's so
much that we can do when it comes to uh
really educating data scientists and and
really making sure really ensuring that
they get
an education that is is is really uh
dynamic and really reflects who we are
renee i think that uh this has just been
an absolutely fascinating discussion i
thank you so much for giving us so much
to think about um at the intersection of
ethics ai and just really what these
these important challenges are as we
begin this conversation we're going to
be having throughout the year and we're
going to look forward to having you
meeting with our um biomedical data
science innovation lab fellows as a
mentor in sharing further some of your
thoughts about this very important space
i want to remind everybody that um
applications for our biomedical data
science innovation lab program are still
being accepted
up until january 31st of 2022 so we look
forward to you uh yourselves um applying
or encouraging your other junior
colleagues or junior colleague
associates to um to apply and we look
forward to being able to review those
applications so that uh uh maybe you or
your colleagues would have an
opportunity to uh meet with uh renee in
person and discuss these very important
topics and with that i want to thank
everybody for joining us today and i
especially want to thank renee for just
a fantastic uh
discussion of just this
hugely important area
really challenging us to think
differently about data activism using
our imaginations and how we apply them
to biomedical data science so thank you
so much renee thank you very much and
thank you everybody for joining us have
a wonderful weekend we'll look forward
to seeing you next week